okay so here's the second or last one
that we have uh I'm pretty confident wow
I am pretty confident I think I am also
confident no actually [__] this could be
either Kaho or
shindo oh [__] actually you're right
you're right kah or sh no con it's like
a mixture of what I think the two of
them were like Macross Frontier so we
have mac so we have digim Digimon
Adventures we have isai quartet we have
some show I've never seen vampire dies
in nose time which is quite recent one
if I'm not mistaken neon J Evangelion AR
akab sa uniform maluk magika oh what is
that middle one at the bottom there I've
seen that before and it's in her
circumstances oh yes you're right and
macro Frontier yeah [__] um I think I no
actually it's it's literally I I I was I
was confident and then I looked at some
of them and I'm like wait I'm leaning
more towards
shinder but some of these choices could
be is also Kaho I'm pretty sure I'm
going to say shindo I I think it's Kaho
I think it's K really I remember brought
up to me Macross more than anyone else
ever in my life K kahoe has brought up
Macross uh in the first podcast that we
recorded I remember she loves Macross
and I believe I remember talking to her
about Digimon as well she does like
Digimon up digim otherwise I would I
would have been like oh this is shindell
right yeah yeah that makes sense all
right who who is
it all right okay wow this is such an in
what is that top right one medier nud it
says oh nud sorry I don't think it's me
oh God P it looks like maybe 80s early
90s maybe yeah so Kaho has watched an
ungodly amount of anime yeah uh I didn't
fully appreciate this when we first had
K on when she started bringing up fake
weebs and I was like I thought she just
meant like some people watch like two
anime but I think she means like 90% of
people who watch anime cuz Kaho has
watched so much anime uh and her
knowledge of it is very impressive so
this this looks like a very varied list
very varied and I wonder why I've always
wondered why Kaho likes Digimon so much
she actually did give me reasonings
though oh she did she did yeah it's cuz
it's the superior Pokemon how [__]
dare okay well is there one you'd like
to know about first I can I can what is
the top right one what is that the top
right one okay Russian okay let me
scroll up okay here we go I have I have
the list yeah um it is is
it I've never seen her before it looks
like a show CH sailor uniform no no
that's a different one no no that's
that's the one on the midle uh
um akazukin Chacha akazukin
Chacha I've seen this around but I have
no is this like a really OG shjo anime
look at that second picture there that
is that is OG shjo
manga says capturing the mesmerizingly
cute art from anime the show manages to
hold both say so Vibe and Yuri fan
service it's a gem wow say so and Yuri
there say so wow wow okay I've never
seen it or heard of it but this is OG
this is very when did it come out can
you can you go the Wikipedia this must
have been pretty old um K was also
mentioned to 1994 yeah K's mentioned to
me in the past that she really likes a
lot of ovas yeah
um I mean the '90s was the [__] Peak
OVA Peak OVA I mean I do kind of miss
the
OVA era of anime just because you had so
many interesting and different [__]
ideas that didn't always appeal to the
mainstream masses but they would be able
to be M just because it was like a three
episode OVA well we'll never get like
another Geno cyber or like violence Jack
or any of those yeah I was talking to C
about it and I was like yeah I really
want to watch more more '90s ovas cuz I
can't remember I watching a show like a
random show from the '90s
and the show did not call for it at all
but randomly like 5 minutes in just
titties and like naked and like it
wasn't brought up in like a sexual way
it was just titties and then just moved
on I was like no sensor bar either
nothing and I was like okay wow geez we
really doing this if you want to see
anime in its roest form then watch a
bunch of 90s yeah everything was weird
that's that's the point it didn't really
matter about appealing to kind of like
writing like a mainstream story people
just had weird [__] ideas that's why
it's so fascinating to go down that
rabbit hole cuz you just find some of
the wildest stories and not everything
is a banger uh not everything is like
the best written story but you will have
a very unique time yeah you will see
some very unique things yeah it's it's
been fun I've been watching what did I
watch one called key the metal Idol have
you heard of this one I have not [__]
weird it's basically like people who are
trying to make
uh robotss that are that you can pilot
via humans but to to Pilot it you need
to take the like soul out of someone and
it's just this weird it's so weird and
it's like 15 episode OVA and it's all
got it's like titties all the time is
this on Netflix no no I just found it it
looked weird and I was like I'll [__]
watch it yeah all of these you just have
to find online so and it's like way too
dark for no reason and it's like a I
kind I kind of [__] this I [__] with
this 90 stuff oh you're going through
your metal face of I'm kind of having a
fun time it's fun just watching these
random shows that are I don't I don't
think they're good or bad I just think
they're weird just fascinating i' I've
been trying to find shows that have no
pre-existing manga and this show was all
just original o weird it's so weird yeah
totally um I mean I think for me aa and
Mok Maga ma Ross and Digimon make a lot
of sense uh you know a KB sailor uniform
that was I never saw that one that came
out recently uh it came out like two
years ago three years
ago when did it come out oh wait
sorry oh sorry sorry
sorry the description I gave was for
sailor uniform capturing me
mesmerizingly cute art from the managed
to hold
say [__] what actually said about
akazuki and chaa is this is one of the
most differently adapted anime from the
manga in 1994 adding magical girl theme
which the original didn't have at all
totally worked wow okay okay and kah
liked the Yuri and Sayo Vibes of AK Chan
yeah cuz I was I was uh going to say
that this this came out yeah last year
okay it wasn't it wasn't too long ago uh
two years ago actually two years ago K's
reasoning for Digimon shut the [__] up
shut the [__] up Joey K's reasoning for
Digimon is the best thing I've ever
heard in my life what so the reason why
K likes has put Digimon on this list she
said I was a student at a Protestant
school I stopped going to church on
Sunday morning for this show and chose
and chose My Religion
[Laughter]
anime B kaho's English is so good that
Kaho used a
semicolon in in a correct way in a
correct way what the [__] my god I've
never used a semicolon I think one time
I used it I to had a quadruple check I
used it right I always get the green
like
squiggly in my word dog it's like I
don't need to use this do I use a colon
or a semicolon here going to Protestant
school and chose My Religion ad hell
yeah that's so good yeah I mean I think
Digimon I mean I being being a digimon
fan myself it was I don't know it was
what I thought people found in Pokemon
which is you you had your animals and
[__] like that uh but to me Djimon just
had a more engaging storyline to me no
totally I mean I watched both uh I
enjoyed both Digimon and Pokémon um I
like as you said I like Pokémon for
completely different reasons to Digimon
um Pokemon is just like heroin of
nostalgia yeah yeah Pokemon is just like
turn your brain off good fun times
whereas Digimon is actually like an
engaging story yeah it has it has a
engaging narrative even for it you know
for it Target demographic until that is
until Pokemon gives you the [__]
Butterfree episode then you're like all
right real [__] real [__] only men cry
to this [__] and the Charizard episode
the leading forward meme oh Charizard
the Charizard [__] me up uh K says for
evang gallion this show made anime more
meaningful to a lot of adolescents even
contributed to forming new categories
like suere and chuni yeah yeah I don't I
don't know what is chuni chuno is like
the the Trope where it's like you think
you have magical powers but you actually
don't you know know that uh and then K
says you just cannot ignore the impact
oh yeah I mean aonami Ray is the reason
why K [__] exist like she there are
so many and Asuka is the reason why tund
are so popular like uh isai quartet I
thought I thought it was rezero but CU I
only just sawai quartet says basically
like Avengers or Justice League of
isekai shows but turning them into Chibi
characters and making them go to school
together could this be more anime the
comedic chaos works so insanely well uh
even even made a movie with solid story
yeah I I enjoyed eai quartet enough just
because hey this is an insane idea let's
just put a bunch of different characters
from different IPS and let's see what
happens
I think the only reason why I liked it
is because all of the isai characters
that are in it are from isai I actually
enjoy yeah
the like I like I like cor I I like
rezero Tanya was was good enough you
know so I'm just like all right yeah all
right cool yeah it was like a nice
little fun show it was like to me it
more felt like fan service than an
actual oh totally than a natural show
you know something like the Avengers
you're like this kind of like built up
to this massive massive narrative point
where all of these different characters
coming together this just more felt like
hey it's it's a nice like what if fan
service show where they all come
together um so it was enjoyable what did
she say about the vampire dies in no
time that's also uh vampires die vampire
dies in no time the Mis stupidity and
comf in is superb in this comedy also
voice fits each character so perfectly
including the singing part it generally
captures the original manga while making
it more colorful and fun I I don't know
this show seen I before this show uh
like first couple of episodes but um
I've heard from a lot of people that
this is actually a really solid show
like solid comy show I knew Kaho would
bring out the uh more the left hookers
yeah yeah the shows that we hadn't seen
as much because kaho's just watched so
many one one thing that I'm very happy
with is that uh she's watched his and
her circumstances and it's been so long
since if if you're talking about a
romance anime that brings back pure
Nostalgia for me it is his her
circumstances which which show is this
bottom bottom what's the Japanese title
of that cuz there's a show called
K uh this was a mass piece of G gyx with
ano uh it's also ano as well and you can
tell cuz the the ending is whack as [__]
the ending is a whack of [__] with cool
Transitions and pacing of its own the
show exemplifies one of the rare times
when I prefer watching anime over
reading manga of the same title for the
animation greatly helps you be
emotionally invested was it was it Kor
used a bunch music from AA or was it the
other way around I think they both use
music from each other shows right yeah I
guess you've made a banger just why not
know well he directed uh Shin Godzilla
as well and he just straight up uses the
the
iconic in like the planning scene and
and I'm like wait hold on hold on a
second ano 2.0 OST is the kako OST yeah
H yeah so ano is just like like yo we
made it I'm a recycle I'm a recycle is
it even the same uh genre it doesn't
matter doesn't matter we're going to
we're going to reuse it uh I asked K
about M magika she says everything about
M magic is unique art style music and
more importantly story considering a lot
of bait and switch shows came after this
the anime was so evolutional that it
made a trend yeah I mean like maduka
magika was kind of the reason why the
whole like deconstruction of genres
thing he started the deconstruction
Trend and then everyone's like wait a
minute does any know what deconstruction
actually means and then everyone's like
wait we just been using that word I
don't know making parodies we got to
think about this it's like when people
finally realize they didn't know what
the word sakuga meant yeah it's just
like we're just using it because it
sounds cool and then ma Ross C says not
only uh the songs by yokoo were bangers
the romantic and professional battle
between two girls was well written plus
the fact the boys boy in the love
triangle was a career Focus pilot who
had a pretty face with the career
background of playing a female lead in
Kabuki gave him more depth than the
typical why does he get to be popular
dudes in har she's she's more in depth
than like 95% of attit the show was
catchy in so many ways yeah it was I
mean yeah it was good I mean Macross
that was like legendary for a reason
that was legendary for his time
legendary in Japan as well legendary 4
its genre it it was also kind of like a
[__] monkey porw I guess because I
think we have matross to thank for Idols
yeah oh God first ever anime Idol was in
m it was it was a Mecca show originally
a Mecca show and there was an idol in it
and then everyone was like wait we
really like this Idol story line and uh
and now we have and here we are how many
years later now we have and and now and
now they're like wait what if we just
removed the meccas and just keep the
idols right yeah damn what could go
wrong and now we have vtubers akb48
pushed their glasses up and was like we
know what to do I feel under qualified
to even rate C list I feel like C list
is is probably good it is yeah it's it's
solid um and very car for sure